[Музика]
мене звати Наталія, і настав час для нашого
уроку англійської мови, тому я сподіваюся, що ви
всі щасливі та здорові, тому що ми знаємо,
що нам потрібно для цього виду спорту та хорошої
їжі, давайте поговоримо про спорт, перш ніж
почати  наш урок Я хотів би подивитися,
що ми робили на попередніх уроках і чого
ми вже навчилися, тому ми пройшли
через усі назви видів спорту, і ми
знаємо, як використовувати ігри і робити з нею Я
сподіваюся, що ви можете пояснити мені, чому ви
подобається чи не подобається спорт і розкажіть
невелику історію про свій спортивний досвід,
звичайно, ми зробили деякі граматичні модальні
дієслова, прислівники та цілі, ми знаємо,
як бути хорошими, але і найкраще, використовуючи
порівняння ступенів, ми знаємо, хто
найшвидший бігун у  світ, але ми також
знаємо, що повільний бігун може виграти гонку,
якщо він або вона продовжує тренуватися і
добре працювати над тим, наскільки небезпечним
може бути спорт, але ми знаємо, що ми повинні або
не повинні робити з цим, ми знаємо, які
м’язи ми використовуємо, коли  ми розмовляємо англійською,
і ви, звичайно, були  ваші домашні завдання давайте
перевіримо це зараз це був експеримент, ви
повинні дотримуватись інструкцій, але
перед цим ви повинні заповнити ці
слова добре, щоб ви могли перевірити це своїм
варіантом
далі це стрибки струмінь означає
стрибки це спосіб стрибка з вашим
голови та ноги дуже широкі добре два
речення, коли ми катаємося на скейтборді, ми
правильно використовуємо м'язи ніг і рук, і нам
потрібен хороший баланс для цього відмінного, тому,
як зазвичай, у нас є перший тест на
початку,
ваше завдання - виправити помилки, я даю вам
дві хвилини, а потім  Я дам тобі свого
Durand, а ти виправиш його
[Музика]
[Музика],
тож ти готовий, давайте перевіримо,
це правильний варіант Паула їдь на велосипеді
після роботи Кейт не хотіла б йти
з нами,
вона ненавидить готувати, ти повинен  не пірнайте в
басейн, це небезпека,
вона не повинна відвідувати лікаря, вона
вивихнула щиколотку, добре попрацювала і не бійтеся
робити помилки, так що citius Altius Fortius
ми вже згадували це слово,
ви пам'ятаєте, що вони означають і який
спор  t подія це приблизно так швидше
вище сильніше це слоган
Олімпійських ігор або Олімпіади, і я сподіваюся,
що в кінці нашого уроку ми
дізнаємося, чому в Олімпійських іграх так важливо
не перемагати, а брати участь, тому подивіться
на ці картинки  все це про Sama
Tokyo Olympic Games 2020, але,
на жаль, через kovat 19 це
буде перенесено на 2021, але дивлячись
на ці фотографії, ви можете побачити види спорту, які
ви вже знайомі, футбол теніс,
велоспорт, біг і так далі, але я
хотів би представити вам більше  такі види спорту,
як гандбол,
і ви можете вгадати кімнати цієї гри
завдяки назві рука та м'яч, це те, що
ви граєте руками та м'ячем фехтування
дуже елегантно Спорт метання
списа веслування важка
атлетика важка атлетика стрільба з лука стрільба з лука гімнастика
тому, а тепер давайте подивимося на Олімпійські ігри
Ігри час від часу перше зображення -
це Олімпійські ігри в Лондоні 2012 року,
а друге зображення - це стародавня рукоятка,
тому ось кілька слів і
словниковий запас, які ви хочете  Мені потрібно
зрозуміти текст на честь Зевса, а не на
груди, щоб відбутися з бабою
Тессою, щоб взяти участь. Браттон chest відбудеться -
з moobot ісса через роки
армія РК буде додана бутик, що розслабляє
двері, денім, щоб отримати винагороду buta Nagarajan
'  m корона з оливкового листя Coronas lisa
lavie e cherry racing pepperoni Nicola
schnitzel,
то дозвольте мені прочитати це для вас Стародавні
Олімпійські ігри перші Олімпійські ігри
відбулися в Греції майже 3000 років
тому вони були атлетичними змаганнями, що проводилися
в порядку Зевса ігри відбувалися
щодня  чотири роки в місті Олімпія
спочатку на Олімпійських іграх була лише одна
подія – короткі перегони через стадіон, але
з роками додалося більше подій
бокс, боротьба в довжину, стрибки в довжину, кидки,
а також обговорювати та ділитися трасуванням,
у змаганнях могли брати участь лише грецькі чоловіки,
переможці  були
нагороджені короною з оливкового листя Олімпійські
ігри були дуже важливими для
стародавнього світу, тому що в період
ігор всі битви  і війни були зупинені,
тому Олімпійські ігри стали
символом миру та дружби, тому ми читаємо
статтю про минулі події, ви
пам’ятаєте, що, коли ми використовуємо минуле просте, ми
повинні змінити своє дієслово у форму минулого,
тому давайте зробимо це зараз, але пам’ятайте, що ми  мають
правильні або та неправильні дієслова так
відбуватися і брати участь у минулому
буде до місця брав участь відбутися
буде відбутися, тому що це звичайний
світ бути доданим ми маємо дієслово to be
in past was added to be rewarded was
rewarded  і стати звичайним дієсловом у
минулому will be стала добре добре, і ви
помічаєте, що тут у цьому тексті є
can, яку ми використовували в минулому в минулому це
буде could could it's минула форма
модального твору can only грецький чоловік міг брати
участь  на змаганнях це
колишня форма роботи моделі може, але тепер
жінки можуть брати участь в Олімпіаді
інший приклад, він не може зараз грати в футбол,
але він міг грати в нього, коли був
дитиною, добре,
зараз виберіть правильний варіант, щоб скористатися ним
ти розумієш  за текстом перші
стародавні Олімпійські ігри відбулися в Римі,
місто Олімпія або Афіни, і правильна
відповідь -
місто Олімпія, переможці отримали
золоту медаль, корону з оливкового листя або
трофей, а правильна відповідь -
натовп оливкового листя вони  чи були атлетичні
змагання на честь євреїв з
продажів або gara правильна відповідь Зевс
молодець і тільки чоловіки тільки жінки, тільки
греки могли брати участь у
змаганнях і правильна відповідь тільки
грек міг брати участь у
змаганнях добре номер частини  дві сучасні
Олімпійські ігри це слова, які вам знадобляться,
щоб побачити Будда, надавши їх, щоб
включити мотив підказка команда кінотеатр бронза
срібло золота медаль бронза солодкість
ляльки отама, яка представляє гордість,
стабільність, щоб показати Пітера Браза ті та
Стенлі принаймні
до 90 років добре перший  сучасна Олімпіада
відбулася в 1896 році в Афінах Греція 218
спортсменів з 14 країн взяли участь у
43 змаганнях багато чого змінилося
з тих пір тепер є не тільки сума  Мер
і зимові Олімпійські ігри, а також
Паралімпійські ігри та Олімпійські ігри йосе та
багато нових спортивних подій,
навіть деякі екстремальні, добре Параолімпійський
це змагання між P
з обмеженими можливостями тіла та Олімпійські ігри Яс,
це ігри для юних спортсменів
від 14 до 18 та  ви бачите, що
скейтбординг зараз - це олімпійський вид спорту добре,
давайте рухатися далі сучасні Олімпійські ігри
відбуваються в різних містах
світу переможці отримують медалі третє
місце виграє бронзу друге виграє срібло
і перше отримує золоту медаль
важливим символом сучасних Олімпійських ігор
є п'ять  кільця кожне з них представляє
один із континентів світу без
сер та Південну Америку Європу Африка Азію
та Австралію Прапор кожної країни
має принаймні один колір, ви
можете побачити карту світу з п'ятьма
кольорами та різними прапорами з усіма
кольорами, які  представляє у п'яти рингах
добре, зараз виберіть правильний варіант перша
сучасна Олімпіада Олімпіада була проведена в
1896 році в Греції в Ессені Gr  eece в 14
різних країнах у Римі і
правильна відповідь - в Афінах, Греція номер
два, сучасна Олімпіада проходять в
різних містах світу,
різні міста Греції або суть,
і правильна відповідь - різні міста
по всьому світу правильні переможці
переможці отримують бронзу  срібний або золотий
трофей корона з оливкового листя або бронза
срібні або золоті медалі і правильна
відповідь - золоті медалі і срібло і
бронза,
а наступне кожне з п'яти олімпійських кілець
представляє колір веселки одного з
континентів світу і
найпопулярніші кольори  і правильною відповіддю
буде так, один із континентів
світу хороший, тож давайте перевіримо, як ви
запам’ятали назву цих країн,
що це за країна так, Японія, це
Бразилія, добре, яка країна це Франція
та Китай, а ця, звичайно,
Сполучене Королівство добре добре, і останнє
завдання щодо цього тексту – порівняти,
як змінилися Олімпійські ігри, добре,
подивіться на першу частину, а потім на стародавню
Олімпіаду  у mpics була лише одна подія, так, коротка
гонка по стадіону, і тепер багато
нових спортивних спортивних заходів включають
навіть скейтбординг, а також
літні
зимові Олімпійські ігри, Паралімпійські ігри та
ігри для кульгання Йоси, ви бачите велику
різницю, ніж могли взяти лише грецькі чоловіки
місце беруть участь у змаганнях
тільки чоловіки, але тепер в Олімпіаді можуть брати участь багато спортсменів чоловіків
і жінок з різних країн
і переможці
були нагороджені короною з оливкового
листя, але тепер переможець отримує медалі
золоті срібні та бронзові, тому він має  змінилося,
але як і тоді, Олімпійські ігри –
це дружба, мир і співпраця
між людьми у світі, це
правда,
це не змінилося,
і тому ми можемо сказати, що дуже
важливо в Олімпіаді не
вигравати, а брати участь і, як зазвичай
наприкінці нашого уроку ви коли-небудь чули про
боротьбу на нозі, це не Олімпійські ігри,
але хто знає, можливо, одного дня це
домашнє завдання номер один складе речення
про себе  f і розкажіть, що ви
не могли або могли робити, коли були
дитиною, і що ви можете робити зараз або не можете
робити зараз, наприклад, коли я був дитиною, я
міг грати в футбол, наприклад, але зараз
я не можу або коли  Я був дитиною, я не вмів
готувати, але тепер я можу номер два, будь ласка,
запишіть усі власні імена, які ви
пам’ятаєте з цих двох текстів, які ми
читали на цьому уроці, ви можете знайти ці
тексти на YouTube, добре, а тепер давайте
подивимося, що ми дізналися  Сьогодні на цьому уроці
ми читали тексти про стародавні та сучасні
Олімпійські ігри та дізналися
про них цікаві факти, ми порівняли стародавні та
сучасні Олімпійські ігри та дізналися, що
вони змінилися, вони дуже змінилися, але
вони все ще символ дружби та
миру, звичайно, ми дізналися  більше спорту, і
ми погодилися, що найважливіше
в Олімпіаді - це не перемогти, а взяти
участь, добре, а тепер дуже дякую,
це кінець нашого уроку, будьте здорові
та щасливі та до побачення
[Музика]